have this problem here from chapter 5 of
the Kotz treichel and Townsend chemistry
and chemical reactivity book and I'm
doing this with their permission so they
tell us that ethanol c2h5oh boils at let
me do this in orange it boils at 78.29
degrees Celsius how much energy in
joules is required to raise the
temperature of one kilogram one kilogram
of ethanol from 20 degrees Celsius to
the boiling point and then change the
liquid to vapor at that temperature so
there's really two parts of this problem
how much energy in joules to take the
ethanol from 20 degrees to 78.29
degrees Celsius that's the first part
and then once we're there we're going to
have 78.29 degrees celsius liquid
ethanol but then we also need the energy
to turn it into vapor so those are going
to be the two parts so let's just think
about just right raising the liquid
temperature raising raising liquid just
raising the liquid temperature let's
figure out how we're going to do that
just the liquid temperature so the first
thing I like this is well how many
degrees are we raising the temperature
well we're going from 20 degrees Celsius
to so we're going from 20 to 20 degrees
Celsius to 70 let me write Celsius
they're just so weak it's clear 20
degrees Celsius to 78.29 degrees Celsius
so how much did we raise it well 78.29
minus 20 is fifty eight point two nine
so our change in temperature our change
in temperature is so our change in
temperature is equal to fifty eight
point two nine degrees and we could
actually fifty eight point two nine
degrees Celsius or this could even be
fifty eight fifty eight point two nine
Kelvin and the reason why we can do that
is because difference is on the Celsius
scale and the Kelvin kiss scale are the
same thing the scale the Cal the Kelvin
scale is just a scaled is just a shifted
version of the Celsius scale if you
added
- 73 - each of these numbers you would
have the Kelvin temperature but then if
you take the difference it's going to be
the exact same difference either way you
do it 78.29 - 20 so that's how much we
have to raise the temperature so let's
figure out how much energy is required
to raise that temperature so we want a
delta T we want to raise the temperature
5850 8.29 of staines Celsius 0.29
actually let me change it to Kelvin
because that looks like what our units
are given in terms of specific heat so
let me write that down 50 8.29 Kelvin is
our change in temperature I could have
converted either of these to kelvin
first then found the difference gotten
the exact same number because the
Celsius scale in the Kelvin scale the
increments are the same amount now
that's our change in temperature now how
much how much ethanol are we trying to
boil well it tells us right over here
tells us that we're dealing with one one
kilogram one kilogram of ethanol and
everything else they gave us is in gram
so let me just write that 1 kilogram
that's the same thing as a thousand
grams we could just write it here 1.000
kilogram is equal to that or let me
write it this way times 1,000 grams per
1 kilogram these cancel out this is the
same thing as one thousand one thousand
grams although the reality is we only
have three significant digits this makes
it look like we have four so we have one
thousand grams times one thousand grams
and then we just multiply this times the
specific heat of ethanol the specific
heat capacity of ethanol right here two
point four four joules per gram Kelvin
so times two point four four joules let
me write it this way two point four four
joules per gram per gram Kelvin you see
that the units work out this Kelvin is
going to cancel out with that company in
the denominator this gram in the
numerator will cancel out with that
grams and it makes sense specific heat
is the amount of energy per mass per
degree that you that is required to push
it
at one degree so here we're doing 58
degrees a thousand grams you just
multiply the units cancel out so you
have Kelvin canceling out with Kelvin
you have grams cancelling out with grams
and we are left with take out the
calculator we take out put it on the
side here so we have fifty eight point
two nine times one thousand times one
two three one thousand times two point
four four is equal to and we only have
three significant digits here so this is
only this is going to be one hundred
forty two we'll just round down 142,000
Kelvin so this is one hundred and forty
mm sorry 140 mm Jules Jules is our units
we want energy so this is how much so
this right here is the amount of energy
to take our ethanol our one kilogram of
ethanol from 20 degrees Celsius to 78.29
degrees Celsius or you could view this
as from 293 Kelvin to whatever this
number is plus 273 that temperature in
Kelvin either way we've raised its
temperature by 58 point two nine Kelvin
now the next step is it's just a lot
warmer ethanol liquid ethanol we now
have to make it we now have to vaporize
it has to become vapor at that
temperature so now we just add we have
to add the heat of vaporization so
that's right here or we call it the
enthalpy of vaporization the enthalpy of
vaporization they tell us is 855 joules
per gram and this is how much energy you
have to do to vaporize a certain amount
or a per gram of ethanol assuming that
it's already at the temperature of
vaporization assuming that it's already
at its boiling point how much extra
energy per gram do you have to add to
actually make it vaporize so we have
this much and we know we have a thousand
grams we know we have a thousand grams a
thousand grams of ethanol the grams
cancel out 855 times 1,000 is 800 and
thirty-five thousand joules so it
actually took it actually took a lot
less energy to make the ethanol go from
twenty degrees Celsius to seventy eight
point two nine degrees Celsius then it
took it to stay at seventy eight point
two nine but go from the liquid form to
the vapor form this took the bulk of the
energy but if we want to know the total
amount of energy we could actually let's
see if we can add this up in our heads
eight hundred fifty five thousand plus
eight hundred forty two thousand eight
hundred plus 100 is nine hundred its
nine hundred thousand fifty plus forty
is ninety five plus two is seven so it's
nine hundred and ninety not nine hundred
ninety seven thousand joules or nine
hundred ninety seven kilojoules or we
could almost say almost it's almost one
mega Joule if we wanted to speak in
those terms but that's what will take
for us to vaporize that one kilogram of
ethanol